so today for our daily cancellation
we're gonna be canceling gender reveal
parties
um because it's happened once again
according to the california department
of forestry and fire protection
some pyrotechnics used during a gender
reveal party caused the forest fire and
the people responsible will face
severe penalties here's the press
release that says cal
fire law enforcement has determined the
eldorado fire burning near oak glen in
san bernardino county
was caused by a smoke generating
pyrotechnic device used during a gender
reveal party
the fire began at 10 23 a.m on saturday
uh
on september 5th 2020 in the eldorado
ranch park cal fire reminds the public
that
with the dry conditions and critical
fire weather it doesn't take much to
start
a wildfire those responsible for
starting fires due to negligence or
illegal activity can be financially
responsible
and criminally responsible so uh so so
far
seven thousand acres of land have been
incinerated because a couple of
narcissists wanted to announce their
baby's gender with fireworks
instead of announcing it by just you
know announcing it
saying something like hey we're having a
girl but no they needed pink flames to
rain down from the sky
lighting up the heavens and declaring
their news unto the whole earth
uh and this is not a new thing by the
way gender-reveal parties seem to
start for forest fires every year in
total about 98
million square miles have been burned
because of gender reveal parties
and two and a half billion people have
died
those are rough estimates don't google
it just just go with it for now
the main point is simply that fires are
no fires
gender reveal parties are stupid
extremely stupid for many reasons but
here's the main one
and i don't mean to disenchant or
demoralize you with this information but
but here it is nobody cares about the
gender of your baby
nobody is on pins and needles needing to
know
you might be but nobody else is i've got
like over
20 nieces and nephews and counting and
that that's one figure that is not an
exaggeration
um i i didn't have a preference for the
gender for any one of them i didn't care
that much
i'm interested to know but it would be
it would be really weird if my sister
said to me hey we're having another baby
and i went
oh boy or girl and she said well if you
want to know come to the park next
friday at 2 30. bring a long chair
uh show starts at 3 what why don't you
just tell me
like i'm not that interested i'll wait
for the baptism if that's how it's going
to be
but see the gender reveal party wouldn't
bother me as much
if it weren't part of a larger trend and
the trend is people in the modern world
deciding they need about 52 public
celebrations and gift-giving occasions
for every milestone milestones that used
to be normal and celebrated you know
once if at all uh and and and with an
intimate
circle of family and very close friends
but now we've decided
that these things which humans have been
doing for millennia are
when we do them anyway historically
momentous occasions and legions of
angels must come from on high
to sound the trumpet and sing choruses
of hallelujahs
consider how many public celebrations a
modern couple might have before they've
even made it around the first
turn on the monopoly board of life first
they have their engagement party then a
bridal shower
then the bachelor party then the
bachelorette party then the rehearsal
dinner the wedding the wedding reception
the post-wedding brunch
if you're counting at home that's eight
parties just because these egomaniacs
are getting married
meanwhile nobody cares that much i mean
we care
but not eight parties worth of caring
and they aren't done yet
not by a long shot when they decide to
have a child there's the gender reveal
party there's the baby shower followed
now by the man
shower which is a baby shower for men or
more precisely for individuals who might
be
mistaken for men then the mother gets a
push present simply for pushing the baby
out
and after that there is i'm told
something called a sip
nc which is a party where people come
and see
the baby we used to call that
seeing the baby now it's a sip and see
make sure to bring a present this will
be the 15th time you give these
psychotic materialists a present
in the past year and a half and at some
point there's going to be a first
wedding anniversary party because that
also is a thing that people do now by
the way apparently
i don't know if you knew that a party to
congratulate themselves
for not getting divorced within the
first 12 months of taking their vows
people have parties for that now and
there will be you know the big first
birthday party for the child
followed i'm sure not far behind by the
divorce party
and then another engagement party and so
on
and on and on until we are all saved by
the sweet release of death
of course with our luck when we die it
will turn out that you know there's a
big
reveal party for each soul to find out
if they're going to heaven or hell
like bite into the cupcake if it's red
inside and tastes like sulfur
i hope you packed your summer clothes um
and
it's kind of strange when you think
about it because by the amount of of
of celebrating we do for these ordinary
life events
you'd think that we in our culture have
a serious and profound
appreciation for their personal
importance and personal
magnitude but that doesn't seem to be
the case
i don't look around at our society and
notice a deep
reverence for marriage and parenthood i
notice in fact the exact opposite
and when you think a little harder about
it you realize that it kind of makes
sense
these parties are not a reflection of
our appreciation for these institutions
and milestones
that's because the parties don't really
celebrate the institutions and
milestones themselves
the parties are a celebration of the
individuals
the individuals are throwing themselves
expensive parties
to give you an opportunity to celebrate
them
as individuals this also explains why
all of these baby and pregnancy
celebrations are popular
in well-off liberal areas where almost
everyone is pro-abortion
what are they doing celebrating what
they believe to be a parasitic
infestation well again
they aren't celebrating the pregnancy or
the baby it's the woman the person
they are gathering to stroke her ego
rather
she has called this gathering she has
summoned them
for the solemn task of kissing her ass
which these days also of course is what
almost the entire wedding reception is
designed to do as well
we joke about women being bridezillas on
their wedding day
and we excuse it by saying well it's her
big day
but first of all just because it's your
big day why should that be an excuse to
act like a raging sociopath
i don't even tolerate that behavior from
my three-year-old on his birthday
you're a grown woman allegedly pull
yourself together
also it's not just your big day okay
it's supposed to be a day for you and
the groom
and the family it's supposed to really
be a day celebrating the marriage
not you the marriage if you're seeing it
as a day
about you that's a bad sign
and that's why i would recommend to any
man out there if you're engaged and your
bride-to-be
is already giving off bridezilla vibes
maybe think about getting out now while
you still can
bridezillas become wife zillas women who
want everything to be about them on
their wedding day
will it turns out bring that attitude
with them into the marriage
when it comes to her narcissism and
self-involvement the wedding is just the
appetizer
you don't want to see the main course
and dessert well dessert is a
70 30 custody arrangement now i was
fortunate that i didn't have to learn
this lesson the hard way my wife was
anything but a bridezilla yet there are
a lot of bridezillas and brosillas out
there
our culture of self-worship is pretty
much designed to create them build them
churn them out like an assembly line and
all of the over-the-top
self-congratulatory pageantry is both a
symptom
and a cause of the problem so i'm
canceling
all gender reveals and other superfluous
celebrations
you will be permitted one wedding
reception
no more than three hours in length and
that's the only public celebration you
get
until your 50th wedding anniversary
needless to say what i am theocratic
dictator
this will be a matter of law violators
will be
thrown into a volcano and that will be a
cause for public celebration
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated